INTRO:
Following the dotcom crash, as money dried
up and the company’s stock crashed 95%,
the executives set up an emergency meeting.
While their eCommerce business was still growing
rapidly, it was far from being profitable.
So, they decided to launch a platform that
helped other companies to build their own
eCommerce websites called Merchant.com.
Hearing this story, you probably thought that
this is how Shopify got started right?
Well, this was actually the story of Amazon
and their diversification effort after the
dot-com crash.
But, this wasn’t actually all that successful.
You see, Amazon’s rapid growth throughout
the 1990s had led to a rather unorganized
business environment which made it extremely
difficult for them successfully launch merchant.com.
So, Amazon quickly dropped the idea started
testing out other paths for diversification.
6 years later though, in 2006, Shopify, leveraged
the same business model as merchant.com, and
they knocked it out of the park.
So, here’s the story of Shopify and how
they showed up Amazon at their own game.
TOBIAS LÜTKE:
Taking a look back, the story of Shopify circles
back to a man named Tobias Lutke who was born
in 1981 in Koblenz, West Germany.
His father was an internal medicine doctor
while his mother was a teacher for disabled
children.
From a very young age, Tobi had a massive
interest in modifying computer hardware and
coding.
So, when he was 6 years old, his parents bought
him a computer similar to the Commodore 64.
And within the next few years, Tobi taught
himself how to write code and develop simple
games.
Despite this innate curiosity to experiment
and learn by himself, it doesn’t seem like
Tobi was a big fan of school.
Whenever a teacher asked him a question, Tobi
preferred to give them smart witty responses
instead of actually answering the question.
And he took shortcuts whenever possible and
tried to pass his classes by spending the
least amount of effort possible.
In my opinion, I think Tobi simply had his
priorities straight from a very young age,
but from his parents’ and teachers’ perspectives,
this was quite concerning.
So, they had Tobi take a bunch of psychoanalysis
exams to identify if he had any learning disabilities,
but they were never able to diagnose anything.
And as Tobi grew older, his behavior from
a traditional perspective simply got worse
and worse.
Tobi says that he had a serious authority
problem and hated answering to teachers.
So, as soon as he could drop out of school,
he did at age 16 from 10th grade.
Tobi went ahead and joined a computer science
apprentice program at Siemens, but he didn’t
like this very much either.
You see, the apprenticeship required him to
use Java which he felt was a super restrictive
programming language.
In this world of restrictions and limitations,
Tobi felt that there was only one true escape
which was snowboarding.
Tobi would regularly go on snowboarding trips
and one of these trips took him to Whistler,
British Columbia where he met a girl named
Fiona Mckean.
As you would guess, these two would fall in
love, and due to the great distance between
Germany and Canada, they would have to figure
out a living situation.
Initially, they agreed to live in each other’s
countries in alternating years.
First, Fiona came to Germany and lived with
Tobi for a year, and then Tobi moved to Canada
to live with Fiona for a year, but he never
came.
SNOWBOARDING BUSINESS:
Despite finding the love of his life, Tobi
was still kind of a bum.
At the end of the day, he was still a high
school dropout that had no idea what he wanted
to do, so he started networking with people
in Canada.
One of the first people he ran into was a
man named Scott Lake.
Scott was a family friend of Fiona and would
regularly come to family events, and this
is when he would meet Tobi.
Tobi was significantly younger than Scott
coming in at 12 years younger, but the two
had several similar interests, and soon enough,
they decided to start a business together
in 2004.
The initial plan wasn’t anything crazy or
revolutionary.
The duo just wanted to sell something that
they were both passionate about, snowboards,
through the internet.
Though the idea was simple, they wanted it
to be personal.
In other words, they didn’t want to just
flip snowboards on eBay.
So, they decided to launch their own eCommerce
website, but all the eCommerce software available
at the time was absolute crap according to
Tobi.
So, Tobi decided to develop his own.
As you might expect with Tobi though, he refused
to use any of the popular programming languages
because he thought all of them were too restricting.
So, instead, he used an obscure Japanese programming
language called Ruby.
Ruby was so obscure that it didn’t even
have written documentation in English.
Luckily for Tobi though, a Danish programmer
named David Hansson would develop a new framework
for Ruby around the same time which made it
much easier for Tobi to code.
This new framework also generated a lot of
interest within the coding space regarding
Ruby which got Tobi involved in several online
forums relating to Ruby.
Tobi shared a lot of his software on these
forums such as his software for processing
credit cards, and he quickly became a leading
voice within the community.
In the meantime, Tobi and Scott were also
packaging up snowboards and sending them to
customers.
But, given all the interest online surrounding
Tobi’s software, it became pretty clear
to Tobi and Scott that selling software was
the way to go.
SHOPIFY:
Despite this grand vision, neither Tobi nor
Scott had much money, so they started raising
money from their friends and family.
They were able to raise a total of $200,000
from 10 people the biggest investors being
Fiona’s father Bruce McKean and Tobi’s
uncle.
Fun fact, this investment would end up making
Bruce a billionaire.
Anyway, using these funds, our duo went ahead
and hired a German programmer named Daniel
Weinand who they consider to be a cofounder
of Shopify.
The name Shopify has actually been around
since the start of the company, but the company
wasn’t actually originally called Shopify.
The company was actually called Jaded Pixel
and Shopify was just the name of the software.
Given the clout Tobi had amongst online forums,
they were quickly able to build up a base
use of customers and start pulling in monthly
revenue of about $8000.
Over the next two years, this number would
grow almost 10 fold to $60,000 per month,
but this also forced Tobi to raise a lot more
money which he didn’t really want to do.
It’s not that Tobi didn’t want to bring
on investors, but rather that he didn’t
want to bring on venture capitalists who he
thought would ruin the company.
Scott strongly disagreed with this perspective
and felt that venture capital was the way
to go.
And given the company’s desperate need for
cash, Tobi gave in and started pitching to
VCs, but no VC really wanted to invest in
an eCommerce business.
They felt like they had already tried that
in the 1990s which resulted in the dot-com
crash and massive losses, so why would they
try that again.
After failing to raise more capital, Scott
would leave the company, and Tobi would become
the CEO of Shopify.
Tobi didn’t really want to be CEO, he just
wanted to code great software, but with the
future of the company at stake, Tobi would
try to teach himself business.
He started meeting with a lot more VCs, but
these meetings just exposed how clueless he
was.
Tobi wasn’t familiar with technical business
terminology like margin ratios, so he struggled
to answer these questions when VCs asked him.
But, Tobi didn’t let this stop him.
After every VC meeting, Tobi would learn about
the terms that he didn’t know which allowed
him to approach the next meeting with just
a bit more knowledge.
Slowly, Tobi’s VC meetings started to get
better and better, but then the 2008 financial
recession hit which basically made it impossible
for an eCommerce company to raise money.
And with that, Tobi knew that he was truly
on his own.
REFORMATION:
The next two years would end up being the
roughest years of Shopify’s history.
Tobi and Fiona had to live with Fiona’s
parents, and her father had to fund payroll
from savings.
Tobi says that the situation was extremely
demoralizing.
Every day at meetings, Tobi discussed the
long-term goals and vision of Shopify, but
the truth was that it wasn’t clear if Shopify
would even survive the next few months.
Tobi refused to focus on the short term though.
He was adamant that they needed to think long-term
for the company to truly be successful.
And since he couldn’t do too much about
the company’s financial situation for the
time being, he decided to focus on building
a phenomenal team.
You would think that Tobi was looking for
genius programmers that were willing to go
all-in on Shopify, but this couldn’t be
further from the truth.
Tobi says that he would hire a team player
over a brilliant jerk any day of the week.
Also, despite all this hardship, Tobi never
pulled an Elon.
He refused to work 100 hour weeks and he refused
to force employees to do that either.
Tobi strongly believes with creative work,
you can’t cheat.
He says that everyone only has 5 creative
hours per day, and trying to work for longer
hours doesn’t lead to better results.
While this strongly goes against all the beliefs
of Silicon Valley, Tobi stuck with it even
during the worst of times.
And as the world slowly recovered from the
financial recession, the interest in eCommerce
started to come back to life, and Shopify
was finally able to achieve profitability
by 2010.
Around the same time, VCs became more open
to investing in eCommerce once again and Bessemer
Venture Partners would agree to invest $7
million into Shopify for 20% of the company
in December of 2010.
The following year, Shopify would raise another
$15 million and in 2013, they would raise
$100 million.
Tobi would top all of this off by taking Shopify
public in 2015 which valued the company at
just over $1 billion.
Tobi had successfully navigated the company
through the recession and built a team that
was stronger than ever before, but Shopify
was yet to even receive their biggest push.
DROPSHIPPING:
Up until this point, Shopify mainly appealed
to small business owners who wanted to expand
their business through the internet.
But in 2017 and 2018, we saw the rise of one
of the most infamous get-rich-quick schemes
of all time: dropshipping.
If you’re not familiar with dropshipping,
it’s basically the idea to start an online
store using Shopify, sourcing products on
Alibaba or Aliexpress, and then linking the
two together.
This way, you don’t have to physically deal
with the product and your job is to just market
it.
While it sounds simple in theory, it’s actually
extremely difficult.
Now, this isn’t to say that you can’t
make great money through dropshipping, but
like with any business, the vast majority
fail and it’s not nearly as easy as the
dropshipping gurus make it out to be.
Nonetheless, this explosive trend towards
dropshipping was extremely lucrative for Shopify
and sent them to the moon.
Shopify reached a peak market cap of $212
billion.
Since then, Shopify stock has actually gotten
destroyed along with the rest of the market
dropping over 60%.
This has crumbled Shopify’s market cap down
to just over $80 billion, but this is really
nothing to worry about.
If we look at Shopify’s revenue and gross
profit graphs, they haven’t even had a single
negative quarter.
So, I find it hard to believe that Shopify
will be fundamentally struggling any time
soon.
As for Tobi, his net worth peaked at over
$10 billion, but it has since cooled down
to just under $6 billion.
Tobi doesn’t really care that much about
these numbers though.
While he’s super passionate about Shopify
and grateful that he’s able to work on what
he loves, he also believes that at the end
of the day, Shopify is just a job.
And no job will ever take priority over his
family or personal health.
Just like at the beginning, it looks like
Tobi still has his priorities straight.
What do you guys think about Tobi’s approach
to business?
Do you agree that humans shouldn’t work
past a certain point regardless of the situation?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you appreciate Tobi being
the number one donator to Team Trees.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.